all right I bring in my compadre from
the NFL Media Group are our information
man deluxe Ian Rapoport how are you sir
on your new landing spot appreciate them
thank you very closely place very cool I
appreciate that I'm very very happy here
and so and thank goodness healthy I
trust everybody healthy in your neck of
the woods as well yeah I mean healthy as
far as the coronaviruses is concerned
not healthy as far as I have a five year
old in the six year old and all they've
been doing is throwing each other off
the walls okay um so you know I mean I
would say confession protocol has been
implemented in my house and we're good
to go
father of the Orion Rapaport joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show so let's get
into what you tweeted about today
definitely intrigued me Jordan love
wildcard of the draft walked me through
your reporting on that one right here
this is really interesting one because
you know so many people I thought
probably around the combine was thinking
all right for quarterbacks Co early
you're thinking you know probably you
know there was a lot of buzz about the
Raiders and Tom Brady which didn't end
up happening but there was buzz about
that and all right so four quarterbacks
probably go in the top 12 and there's
your quarterbacks and now I'm not so
sure because I think Jordan loves taped
two years ago was really really good the
person people like interviews have been
good the tape last year was not good and
so I think teams are trying to figure
that out and like what kind of prospect
is he actually and you know certainly
someone who is probably not gonna you
hope not going to play in the 2020
season just to sit and learn so it
doesn't feel to me from the people I've
spoken with like that sounds like
someone who goes early in the top ten I
mean just look at the draft let's assume
just for the sake of this argument that
jordan loves gets by gets by the raiders
who actually takes a quarterback they're
like there's just it's a vast array of
non quarterback teams you know maybe
someone like the you know patriots or
packers or something trades up you know
are the saints a team with an entrenched
veteran Brian Hoyer Aaron Rodgers
obviously Drew Brees would be the
veterans there
I say with a little bit of best but that
would be the thought is someone in the
late teens potentially trading up for
Jordan love and having them sitting here
okay and then I mean how does that not
other than the tape doesn't speak very
well I mean it just continues to sound
like the connective tissue to the
Patrick mahomes story right that the
guy's got a ton of talent an absolute
ton of natural talent and and doesn't
have to play for a year and can learn a
system and then year two off we go
maybe wets his beak a little bit in a
week 17 start so but walk me through
what evaluators are saying about Jordan
love that might not be so mahomes ish
what you hear well there is definitely
some home stuff there because you can
watch them make certain throws just kind
of a loose athleticism the way he kind
of carries themselves is success in a
similar system there's a lot of mahomes
there but I think we you know last year
Utah State decision-making not good just
you know inaccurate throws I'm just pure
inaccuracy I mean I think that's the
kind of thing that they're having
trouble with so it's like there's so
much to like form a just pure ability
standpoint like he looks like a pitcher
like he the way he delivers it is so
fluid and so athletically
you know you can you can take that and
turn it into a football player and just
might not be there yet and what's
interesting
similar to mahomes like that causes you
to slide a little bit because you don't
know what you're actually getting and
probably ends you up with a better team
and I think for my home as it worked out
pretty good of course it did Ian
Rapoport here on the Rich Eisen show you
said years we haven't spoke to a single
team that does not believe burrow be
number one you haven't heard from a
single person that does not think that
the cater just through 60 touchdowns
isn't the first overall pick in the
draft the the obviously the combine his
statements at the combine as well as
what's going on in the real world
obviously is knocked this story off of
what was a huge smoke and maybe
potentially fire story in January and
then at the Super Bowl Baro not wanting
to go to Cincinnati is there anything
you're hearing that somehow some way
that the bangles do not take borrow or
borrow forces his way to somewhere else
you got anything on that front I haven't
heard any any anything to lead me down
that path I mean they have spent the
Bengals have spent a lot of my former
colleague and our former colleague other
beer mentioned this yesterday the
Bengals have maxed out their video time
with Joe borough that is definitely true
I mean they have gone above and beyond
the kind of conversations they've had
with him talking about plays and play
books and you know what he's a draft guy
she can actually discuss everything they
have gone deep with him on football on
getting to know him and it sounds like
it's gone really well I mean I and then
the other thing is you know from the
bengal sources I have spoken with when I
mentioned a possible trade they almost
like waved me off it's like come on bro
I come on thanks I think this is
probably as clear number one pick as
we've had in a long time the film is
just you know poised accuracy
decision-making big moments just non
non-stop I mean it this seems like
probably the most obvious choice in a
very long time and so the the to of
market I've talked about this with Peter
King yesterday in and how the to a
market is an iffy subject seemingly all
of a sudden despite despite the video
that came out that shows him looking
spry and and the question about the to a
market and Justin Herbert and the
evaluation Mel Kiper
having Herbert over to in his mock draft
to Miami what are you hearing about on
that front behind burrow and the
quarterback scenario I I wouldn't be
that surprised if Herbert goes over to
ax
he's just there's a lot of fewer
questions I mean have some questions
with Herbert where it's like you want a
little more and I think anyone who's
spent time watching them just from the
TV copy not altering it just like the
regular TV copy of Herbert you say
there's so much there I want a little
more some more plays but as far as
questions ago that's basically it like
he's a good smart kid looks like a
quarterback great hair I mean there's a
lot to like that with too
there's just a lot more questions and
the problem is rich everything health
lies he has done perfectly scans are
great
you have no loss of blood whose
mobilities great deal except logic it
looks like a quarterback you still don't
know what's going to happen in like
three years or two years or five years
or twenty years it just you just can't
predict it and so no amount of
discussions will help you predict what's
going to happen basically to his body
and then the other thing is like we're
talking about with Jay and lug once you
get like let's say somehow that the
Chargers go you know what we're rolling
with Tyrod we're gonna take a left
tackle and we're just gonna be okay well
then who actually takes to it like when
if he gets past six hmm I mean maybe the
Raiders but like actually who and that's
and that's one thing I'm gonna have to
make my sort of make sense of come draft
night is like if he starts to slide
where the teams that will come grab him
well what about Jacksonville I mean
Jacksonville sitting there towards the
end of the the the front ten and and
they have Gardner Minshew obviously
Minshew mania was terrific the question
is is how it's sustainable might he be
is a quarterback in this league as a
starting quarterback in this league
Cam's out there Jameis is out there
Dalton's out there what do you think of
the Jaguars market and thoughts and then
of course you've got those veterans
sitting out there if you can put those
all together for me
yeah yeah I think for the quarterback
market for the Jaguars and I've heard
some Dalton's stuff I know they're
interested I don't think they trade for
any Dalton but I know that they are
interested in him as a possible backup
if he gets released I have not heard
anything and I do believe at some point
they bring in a backup quarterback I
just I haven't heard that they would
take a starting quarterback in the top
ten I mean to me they seem more like
team that either one could trade out and
just fill different holes on the roster
or like you know like Isaiah Simmons
would be someone well you can see if
he's even there just moving them all
around the defense and having some fun
that you know being sort of like the
kind of like can chancellor basically
in that Seattle ish season I just for
them I mean they seem like they're going
forward with Minshew mania and the trail
of Nick Foles to me all but solidified
that because they weren't even gonna let
a training and competition happen it is
all you know mustache going forward for
Jackson walk so what about Jameis and
Cam anybody talking to them right now
they're just gonna wait till after next
Thursday see what's up cam once cam
wants to be a starter a I mean I would
say at least the chance to compete for a
starting quarterback job I don't I don't
see one out there right now so my sense
is cam is gonna wait until there is one
you know like he's got money obviously
it's not like he needs it I would not be
surprised as he can waiting and it's
August and there's a quarterback injury
and there's cam still available huh you
know I mean it's basically basically the
same answer that Sam Bradford was except
you don't have to trade for him and then
there's Jameis I mean and then there's
Jameis who you know I'd be honest like I
was a little bit surprised that he
didn't end up back in Tampa backing up
lumber ad I feel like that would have
been a good opportunity for him that's
another one where you know I haven't
quite found a spot for him and I'm he's
going to sign I imagine he'll be on the
team probably not going to be for a lot
of money he'll be a backup I just think
you know unless I'm crazy it'll probably
be whoever misses on they preferred you
know early to mid round quarterback in
the draft probably says you know what
I'm now gonna sign Jameis for a couple
million a year and whatever I get I get
you can Rappaport here on the Rich Eisen
show you also said Jake from is suddenly
rising up boards or at least creating
some buzz walk me through the
quarterback draft board after love which
obviously includes Herbert to and
Burrell above him walk me through that
how you're seeing everything I think
it's you know right now it seems it's
Jacob Eason who is another one who looks
just like a quarterback has an
incredible arm you know throws are like
a baseball player and sometime
doesn't always exactly reach the
intended target I mean I've heard
anything from him from east and from you
know maybe late one to like fourth round
her I think he's kind of old and map I
think Jalen Hertz has had a really
really good pre-draft time you know to
me going in I felt like he was a fourth
rounder going into say like the Senior
Bowl of the combine and now I wouldn't
be surprised in the second round there
you know it seems like maybe the Raiders
take him in the second round or
something like that
Packers Chargers you know if they go
tackle I think you know Hertz is
probably looking pretty good there and
then Jake Fromme has has been really
interesting you know because he didn't
have a pro day and if he had a pro day
you you know you'd probably see some
throws that maybe he didn't make because
he doesn't have a great arm that
wouldn't have been a great look for him
instead you know I guess the only person
to have her have a positive with the
coronavirus know pro day so it's been
all discussions and video conferences
and he's brilliant coaches love them I
could see him as a third rounder and
then you know he either becomes Case
Keenum or Kirk Cousins or it becomes
chase Daniel who plays very little and
is very very rich that is one way to put
it right there
are the Patriots in the quarterback
conversation for the draft and if so how
I mean walk me what through your
reporting on what New England's
quarterback room is going to look like
this fall and and how it might be
affected over what happens next weekend
yeah I would say the Patriots are very
firmly in the quarterback mix they are
just they're so far back you know so I'm
I'm having trouble figuring out like
what are they actually going to do
because you know they're up in the 20s
mm you know jordan loves sliding into
the teens and then grabbing him is a
scenario that I've thought a lot about
they also had some success with Jimmy
Garoppolo in the second rounds so maybe
they try to repeat that I just they
don't have a second rounder so they
either could trade back and create one
maybe or they could use some third and
fourth and trade up in the first I just
the Patriots are going to take a
quarterback probably with a premium pick
I would just imagine it's not at the
pick they currently have so I would I
see the Patriots moving up for a
quarterback or sliding back and then
maybe also taking a quarterback well I
mean obviously you know teams are gonna
show their hand before draft at all and
the Patriots never show their hand and
Bella Czech speaking yesterday I mean
good luck trying to figure out how they
evaluate Stidham long-term or you know
he's asked about Brady and his response
was essentially yeah we we went through
all that and I guess his Aston answered
was never being asked and his answer was
in his press release statement you know
that's just that's just uh it was
classic up a New England to just shut
the whole thing down but you know I
guess that's the question is how does
Belichick view Stidham right now on him
and McDaniels view Stidham he could love
them we have no earthly idea do we at
all my my understanding is they they
very much like Stidham they think his
potential is great they there's there's
a lot of positivity and a lot to like
the problem is they don't actually know
because he's never done it and he's
never I mean you know he's been in games
but it's when you're the guy life is
different right like you spend your life
doing interviews and and production
meetings and you're the leading meetings
and you're taking responsibility which
is very very hard because sometimes
people are not entirely nice to you and
when you throw an interception
it's just life is a starting quarterback
is hard and they don't know how he would
react and so I don't think that they're
going into the draft saying all right we
got stood and we are good like say like
the Chiefs did with the Holmes like it's
not like that
I think it's we're gonna add to the
quarterback room we'll put them together
in you know God willing July in August
and see what happens I mean my guess
right now is Brian [ __ ] and starting
quarterback in the Patriots in 2020 but
I think that is something that will be
ever-evolving as we get through next
season
Ian you're the man thanks for the time
we'll chat next week always enjoy
hanging out rich thank you have you got
it thanks very much Ian Rapoport here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here